[Music]
what is up everybody
Anna Mack here for anime uproar and you
guys voted for it pretty convincingly so
in this video we will be looking at the
Ackerman family sometimes called the
Ackerman clan and why this particular
group of people just happen to be some
of the most powerful warriors in the
world of attack on Titan we will be
covering the history of the Ackerman
family and every known Ackerman in the
series including of course Levi and
Mikasa but also other members of the
family that you may not know about some
quick news before we begin we are
organizing a create your own attack on
Titan character contest here on the
channel and specifically if there was
another Titan shifter in the story that
we still don't know about and you could
be the one to create it what would be
that Titans name what would be their
special abilities and what would be the
current users backstory you can submit
your ideas to us either on Twitter or
Instagram at anime our link in the
description just reply to the thread in
the link or you can submit it through
this cord the link is also in the
description entries can only be 200
words max altogether if you want them to
count the winning design will be brought
to life by professional artist Cuusoo
Murray and he already brought to life
the winning entry in our last contest
for creating your own my hero academia
character this is synchros submitted by
gravity falls congratulations and I
can't wait to see all of your attack on
Titan entries if you enjoyed the attack
on titan content on this channel you can
let me know by leaving a like and if
you're new don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell this video
will contain some manga spoilers
pertaining to the Ackerman's in
particulars so a heads up on that
although the vast majority of the
material we cover here will be covered
at some point in season 3 of the anime
nonetheless if you don't want any
spoilers beyond the anime this is your
warning even though the Ackerman's live
within the walls along with everyone
else they are part of a unique minority
bloodline and this sets them apart from
the rest of the population
the Ackerman family is a bloodline of
superior warriors who in the past served
the royal family and the common belief
is that they were essentially the royal
family's elite bodyguards
however after the 145th king decided to
build the walls and manipulate the
memories of everyone inside the walls so
that they would forget about the outside
world the minority bloodlines did not
forget and eventually they rebelled
against the Kings plan to live in peace
within the walls by forcing everyone to
remain ignorant about the outside world
as a result of their refusal to go along
with the Kings plans the royal family
began to fear the Ackerman's because
they could not control them like they
could control the rest of the population
military forces loyal to the king such
as the first interior squad persecuted
the Ackerman's and other minority
bloodlines including the Asian clan to
the brink of extinction and when the
official story begins there are only a
handful of members left hiding in the
underground city like Levi or on the far
out skirts of the kingdom like Mikasa
and her family in order to end the
persecution and save the Ackerman family
from extinction several generations of
gold the head of the Ackerman family
sacrificed his life by giving himself up
to the king and convincing the other
Ackerman's not to tell their children
about the world beyond the walls the
head of the Ackerman family was executed
but the Ackerman bloodline survived
because despite not having their
memories altered the new generation of
the Ackerman family simply did not learn
about the outside world so they ended up
essentially in the same boat as everyone
else although they were still persecuted
without even knowing why so why were the
Ackerman such a threat to the royal
family why did the royal family fear
them along with the fact that as a
minority bloodline the Ackerman family
couldn't be controlled by the king and
there is also a very specific reason for
why the Ackerman's are such powerful
warriors and why Mikasa Kenny and Levi
are among the absolute strongest
characters in the series at this point
you will remember that at the beginning
of the video I've warned about spoilers
so no complaints later but in the manga
we eventually learned that the reason
why the Ackerman family is so strong is
that they are a byproduct of Titan
science we don't know exactly what this
means but because Titans and
Titan shifters in particular have
amazing superhuman abilities the fact
that the Ackerman family is a byproduct
of Titan science suggests that they also
have superhuman abilities and in fact
the Ackerman's are able to attained an
awakened power at some point in their
lives that appears to give them
superhuman strength speed and agility
and it seems that this awakening is
triggered by a traumatic experience in
their life for Mikasa this was when her
parents were killed by human traffickers
and Levi confirms that both he and Kenny
went through a similar awakening at some
point in their lives as I said the
specifics of how the awakened Ackerman
power actually works and what exactly
Titan Sciences are all still very murky
but I made an entire video a while back
talking about this exact thing in that
video I talked about the connection
between titans the Ackerman's and
science and I argued that the true
origins of the Titan and Titan power are
far different from what we have been
told so far feel free to check out that
video when you finish watching this one
the link is in the description and I
will also link it at the end of this
video but now let's talk about all the
known members of the Ackerman family
let's start off with mr. Ackerman first
name unknown the father of Mikasa mr.
Ackerman lived in a forest outside of
the shegaon chena district with his wife
and daughter the reason why they lived
in one of the outermost districts in the
kingdom and in the forest rather than in
a city is because they were afraid that
the government was going to persecute
them due to the fact that both of
Micah's as parents are part of minority
bloodlines mr. Ackerman is of course an
Ackerman and Micah's mother was part of
the Asian clan later on in the manga we
learned that this bloodline came to
paradise from another nation known as
his uru and from what we see about their
culture in history his aru is directly
inspired by Edo period Japan even their
form of government is a Shogunate the
other Ackerman's in the underground city
were aware that a branch of the family
had escaped to the outskirts of the
shegaon China District meaning mr.
Ackerman's branch of the family from
what we do know about mr. Ackerman he
was cheerful hardworking and a good
husband and father he and his wife were
killed by human traffickers when they
tried to kidnap Mikasa and her mother we
do not know if mr. Ackerman ever
awakened to his inner Ackerman powers he
was killed by the human traffickers so
that could suggest that he hadn't
experienced the moment of awakening
because otherwise we can assume that he
would have been able to defend himself
but the attackers also did have the
element of surprise so perhaps mr.
Ackerman just didn't have enough time to
act next up is his daughter Mikasa
Ackerman
Mikasa awakened to her acraman powers as
a child during the confrontation with
the human traffickers who murdered her
parents after Aaron killed the first two
human traffickers but was then caught
off guard by the third Mikasa
experienced a moment in which he felt a
great surge of power and knew exactly
what to do this is what happens when a
member of the Ackerman clan awakens to
their inner powers Mika says purpose in
life is protecting Aaron because Aaron
saved her life after her parents were
murdered right in front of her and his
family adopted her when she had no one
else in the world
Aaron motivated her and gave her a
reason for living when she had nothing
in the world and no one else to turn to
and Micah's also made a promise to
Aaron's mother Karla that she would
always protect him Mika says currently
19 years old after the latest time-skip
in the manga she was 9 years old when
she was adopted by Aaron's parents and
she is 15 during the majority of the
attack on Titan storyline before this
latest time-skip
like the other Ackerman's whose inner
power has awakened Mikasa is an
outstanding fighter she was the
top-ranked recruit in the 104th Training
Corps and one of the best trainees in
the history of the military in the manga
it is revealed that on her mother's side
Mikasa is descended from his uru Shogun
clan so in other words Mikasa is a
member of his Uno's royal family then we
have Levi Ackerman Levi was born into
poverty and misery in the underground
city beneath the capital of Mithras his
mother couch al Ackerman was a
prostitute who died when Levi was still
a child and he was taken in and raised
by couch Hills brother and Levi's uncle
Kenny Ackerman
although Levi did not realize that Kenny
was his biological uncle until much
later
Levi's mother couch L was of course
herself a member of the Ackerman family
but we know very little about her other
than the fact that she lived in the
ground that she worked in a brothel that
she decided to try to take care of Levi
on her own even though her brother Kenny
advised her not to keep the child so she
clearly was a loving mother despite all
of her struggles and we also know that
she unfortunately died of illness while
Levi was still very young after Kenny
taught Levi how to fight and take care
of himself
Levi became a notorious thug in the
underground before eventually joining
the survey Corps he rose to the rank of
squad captain and served as leader of
the Special Operations squad within the
survey Corps at some point in his life
Levi awakened to his inner powers and
today he is widely known as humanity
strongest soldier now in his 30s Levi is
so strong that he even managed to defeat
the beast Titan who was at the time
Marlay strongest warrior Levi remains
one of the most powerful characters in
the series as of chapter 108 of the
manga and he is also easily the biggest
clean-freak
in the world of attack on titan which
probably has to do with the fact that he
grew up in very unsanitary
poverty-stricken surroundings next is
Kenny Ackerman Levi's biological uncle
Kenny was the one who taught Levi
everything he knows
Kenny's appearance appears to be
directly inspired by Clint Eastwood in
his famous western movie roles and
unlike his nephew Levi Kenny is a tall
and imposing figure at 190 centimeters
or about six feet three inches in height
like Myka son Levi Kenny has awakened to
his ackerman powers at some important
point in life he felt a strange surge of
power and knew exactly what to do in his
early days he was known as Kenny the
Ripper and at that time Kenny was a
notorious serial killer who was said to
have killed over 100 members of the
military police brigade we can assume
that he was targeting the military
police in particular because the
government was still persecuting members
of the Ackerman family at that time
eventually Kenny tried to assassinate
the Reese royal family but he failed to
take out the head of the family URI
Reese who used the founding Titan power
to defeat Kenny but instead of killing
him URI Reese apologized to Kenny for
the persecution that the Ackerman family
has faced eventually Kenny made peace
with
the king and became his bodyguard and
friend and because of this the
persecution of the Ackermann stopped
sometime later he found his sister dead
in the underground and decided to raise
her son Levi in her place after uri
reese died and passed the founding titan
power on to Frieda Rhys Kenney formed an
elite squad of the Military Police
Brigade called the anti-personnel
control squad the official reason for
forming this squad was to keep the
survey corps in check but in reality
Kenny's goal became attaining the power
of the founding Titan for himself after
he learned that the full power of the
founding titan can only be harnessed by
someone with royal blood Kenny as an
acraman without royal blood became
disillusioned and ultimately abandoned
his goal and finally we have grandfather
Ackerman the grandpa of Kenny and cooch
shell and Levi's great-grandfather when
we first meet him at as part of Kenny's
flashback and he is already old and
frail and on his deathbed grandfather
Ackerman was planning to take the
secrets of the Ackerman family to his
grave in order to protect the rest of
the family from information that could
make them a target for the military but
after realizing the family is in dire
straits he decides to tell Kenny the
truth about why the monarchy fears and
persecutes the Ackerman's the
grandfather told Kenny about the power
of the Titans the manipulation of
memories and how the Ackerman family was
dangerous because as a minority
bloodline they could not be manipulated
by the king so it is thanks to
grandfather Ackerman that we learned the
truth about the Ackerman family their
history and their unique awakened powers
and that is it
the Ackerman family and every known
Ackerman explained please don't forget
to enter to create your own attack on
Titan character contest hit us up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime up roar
links are in the description or submit
your entries on our discord link also in
the description the winning design will
be brought to life by professional
artists whose omadi
I will leave his links in the
description as well if you want to see
more samples of his work and displayed
calm has agreed to sponsor this contest
and they will send the winning design as
an incredible metal poster to the winner
and to myself that means that if you win
you will get a high quality
physical copy of your design for
yourself for free so be sure to check
out this play comm to see what kind of
posters they make again link in the
description if you enjoyed the attack on
titan content on this channel and you
want to see more leave a like to let me
know and of course if you're new don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell as always thank you
all so much for watching really
appreciate it and until next time see us
face cowboys
[Music]
you